في سنوات المراهقة المبكرة ، قال الجراح العام في الولايات المتحدة
إن الأطفال ما زالوا يطورون
هويتهم ، ويمكن أن يكون لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تأثير كبير على البيئة المشوهة والمشوهة في كثير من الأحيان
لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي
غالبًا ما تلحق الضرر بالعديد من هؤلاء
الأطفال ، ولهذا السبب يقول الدكتور فيفيك مورثي إن
13 عامًا ما زالوا  أصغر من أن يكون الأطفال على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، ولكن لا يمكن أن يكون ذلك بعيدًا عن الجوانب ،
ربما
يعتمد على طفلك الذي تعرفه ،
تقول أريانا هويت ، أخصائية علم النفس للأطفال في مستشفى نيشن وايد للأطفال ، إن تحديد ما إذا
كان الطفل مستعدًا لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يبدأ
بهذه الأسئلة  هل لديك علاقة منفتحة وموثوقة
مع طفلك ،
فهل سيحترمون الحدود
والتوقعات التي حددتها ، هل سيأتون
إليك إذا كانت هناك مشكلة أو قلق أيضًا ، ضع في اعتبارك أيضًا
شخصيتهم ، هل
يهتمون حقًا بما يفكر فيه الآخرون
بشأنهم أو هل يشعرون بالراحة تجاههم؟
حدد كيف هم مع
ضغط الأقران لأن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مرة أخرى هي
نوع من فتح العالم لكل ذلك
إذا أجبت على هذه الأسئلة وشعرت
أنهم مستعدون ، يقول هويت لإعداد
خطة وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للعائلة وأنت تتحدث
عن الأمان الذي تتحدث عنه  حول ما
تنشره حول كيفية التفاعل مع
الآخرين الذين تتابعهم واستمر في
التحقق من الطفل ووضع
حدودًا ، ضع في اعتبارك أخذ الأجهزة بعيدًا في
وقت النوم حتى لا يتأثر النوم ، فكونك جاهزًا
لا يعني أنني سأعطي
يمكنهم الوصول إلى هذا الشيء والابتعاد ،
ما زلت تريد التفكير في كيفية
مراقبة كيف يمكنني الاستمرار في البقاء في
شراكة معهم حول كيفية
استخدامهم له للصحة دقيقة أنا Mandy
Gaither
[موسيقى]